the thing is like uh six years ago i
i was practically engaged with an ex but
things fell apart because she
[Music]
um cheated on me after we have we had
some
uh financial problems right so
after that experience meaning meaning
you had financial problems
of course because i was the one that
paid for everything yeah so
so what happened there was she didn't
see you as her best option hypergamy
women always seek the best they can get
so she starts exploring other options
you know that women when they're in
relationships about 50 of women have
admitted that they have a backup plan
so oh yeah yeah and you have to keep in
mind that you know that that relies on
on making women look bad so admitting
that you have a backup plan makes you
look bad which tells me that there's a
lot more that are unwilling to admit
that they got something that they might
be considering so when [ __ ] starts to go
downhill for you and this is where the
black pillars get pissed off they're
like see i told you she only wants you
for your money
so when things start to go downhill for
you that's when she starts looking at
other options that's when other guys
start to look more attractive when
you're on your purpose when you're in
your grind when you're chasing
excellence when you're doing something
of some significance with your life
other guys are invisible
yeah and here's where the second part of
the story comes because and confirms
what you're saying
and then i after we broke up
i dedicated myself to study in order to
enter into the
diplomatic in
the diplomats academy of my country
which is basically what you need to do
to be a where you live i live in chile
chile okay cool all right yeah
i thought
many people in the chat probably doesn't
even know where my country is
it doesn't matter i mean i would bet
some of them know i mean i certainly
know where it is
the thing is
i achieved this job it
required me to
pass a very difficult test almost 600
people were
competing in the
to get the job and only 15 remain
and
well basically everything in my life
went up i
started making more money and everything
and all of a sudden
i got a message on instagram
from this chick
i never saw songs
no of course i never talked about
because i put that info on the instagram
page yeah
yeah um
and and of course she contacts me and
tells me like she's changed and she's
been thinking about this thing and he's
been watching she made a mistake she
really loved you she shouldn't have done
that blah blah blah
yeah um
you know why i know what she told you
because i've heard the same story like
at least twice
every every guy watching this right now
that's been with a few women has heard
this story before
some [ __ ] chick that like breaks
their heart cheats on them or some [ __ ]
like that dumps them and then later on
down the road they come across you on
social media women love using facebook
and instagram for creeping people
especially their exes so you know when
they find out oh look rich has a mclaren
he's doing well he's got a show with all
this audience blah blah they you know
the book exists all of a sudden the
shit's blowing up hey you know we
shouldn't have done that when i was in
my 20s i really liked you back then i
was such a [ __ ] idiot and i'm like
[ __ ] aren't you married and you've got
two kids with this guy like what are you
bothering me for
oh yeah yeah yeah
dude there's no shame there's there's no
limits at all
i'm just saying and
i was
of course
i was super beta like the only thing
that carried me you didn't take her back
did you
almost like almost that's the next part
of the story
okay i started reading the unbroken
alpha for a reason i was super beta
before okay because i was raised by a
single mom and i never had any like
powerful male figures to follow so i was
totally fine
romantic listen it's it's totally fine
when you're a teenager but as soon as
you're out of the house and you're an
adult you have no excuses like you like
you have to find those role models you
have to pursue masculine pursuits you
have to look for the truth you have to
question things um but yeah i mean
listen we've all been lied to to some
degree it's just the amount of crap that
you got in your childhood is different
from other guys but
so
you had to unplug and then like why did
you say no to this girl when she came
back to you
okay no i never said no
you didn't say no back
i invited her to my to my apartment and
we had a fantastic night like
super romantic i
i banged her all night and she was
telling me that she loved me that she
missed me that she i was always in their
heart and all this stuff and i was like
wow i was like
mind blown like this is amazing like
because i love the girl right
how much of it did you believe
everything until the next morning okay
and what happened woke up
and the moment i woke up
a dude started calling her and they dude
called her like seven times in a row and
she started like uh
cutting him off right and it was not
crazy
uh no it's just a guy
he's just a friend
no no things didn't work out with this
guy don't worry about it and i was like
okay
we started showering and all and
then
like she started telling me things about
her life and every single thing that she
was telling me was a red flag like it
was a collection of red flags one of
them
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna ask you to
pause on that thought for a second
because i pulled this up i was searching
for it there's this meme that you know
has been going around a little bit and
it's uh
the hairstyle girls love
and there's
same guy same outfit with two different
backgrounds
so fellas take notes because this is the
hairstyle that girls love it doesn't
matter what your hairstyle is it's
what's around you that they look at
which is why when his situation improved
and his and his lifestyle got better she
all of a sudden become interested again
right
sorry go ahead though and then well
she told me that
she was
still friends with her ex
that her ex was now the boyfriend of his
best friend she's best her best
girlfriend
that both of them had the keys to her
house
all of them have the keys to the house
okay
yeah red flags yeah not only that she
had a car parked on her house that was
the car of another guy that she was
seeing at some point
and the car was there because she was
managing this uh selling the car
and i was like what is this okay so what
did you do with all that
i i went after that i went to i drove
her i have a motorcycle as well
so i i i liked that you referred to that
on your book
uh i drove her to her house and then i i
called her and i told her
there's no place for me in your life
like we you have to get rid of all this
[ __ ]
and then we can see what happens and she
was like no i'm fine as i am and i'm
like okay
it's over
let me just she's like
yeah let me just stop you there so
when you identify a woman is broken
she's she's broken i mean there's not
many women that will try to fix their
lives when they got a bunch of red flags
it's really not even worth it like i
like if you're talking a woman she's got
like six or seven red flags and you're
like you know what you gotta go fix your
[ __ ] and then i'll continue you know
with you maybe after that
i wouldn't even go there i would just
say you know
i don't want to invite you into my life
because you're gonna complicate it
unnecessarily
or don't even say that and just you know
if you want to set her up for friends
with benefits and have fun then do that
i don't care but you never ever ever
invite a woman like that into your life
you don't like it's not even like fix
those things that come back and hang on
a sec i'm gonna tell you why
women really struggle with
accountability
okay
men
really like to be accountable
successful guys any any guy that's done
anything with their life is
always accountable they'll always
examine themselves like the other day um
i was late going to see my uh folks and
um you know my kid was running behind
i'm like [ __ ] why you know why is this
taking so long and it's like you know
what i let her sleep in too much right
like i should have got her up early so
she was ready to go and i'm taking
ownership for those [ __ ] thoughts but
women don't like to take ownership you
know for the sorts of results that they
get out of life it's it's always
somebody else's fault
always
right so
one one red flag that's something simple
like
i don't know she has a shopping
addiction for example she likes to buy
[ __ ] and return it and buy [ __ ] and
return it she's one of those people okay
well if she stops doing that maybe you'd
consider it but like six or seven red
flags dude it's not even it's like you
know what if you want to bang come on
over you know
let's do it but i'm not gonna
trust me that's it all right
yeah i should have done that i should
have done it because it would have saved
me a lot of pain thing is i
after i said that to her she told me
like dude you're magnificent you're
wonderful whatever and
like
a week passed and i was like two like i
started to have doubts like i doubted
myself and i called her back and i was
like
let's hang out
the only reason why you did that able is
because you didn't have other options
if you had other women that were
genuinely interested in you
you wouldn't have thoughts about dealing
with a woman with red flags you wouldn't
miss her after a week because you've got
two or three other girls in your phone
that are genuinely interested in you
that are willing to meet up with you
right yeah
yeah it's so possible it was it was
right in the middle of cobit so it was
very you know what dude there's um
there's a video that i um commented on i
was going snowmobiling that day i did it
in the car and i was listening to a clip
from tony robbins about raising your
standards and i'm not a rah-rah-rah you
know success porn sort of like tony
robbins guy where you get you know like
yell in an audience but he's absolutely
right the reason why
guys
invite
you know like pretty much everybody that
calls in on the show it's like you know
i was 35 and she was 40 and she was in
debt and she needed money for a cat and
she had two kids and you know blah blah
blah it's like
huh okay and then you know it's like you
have very low standards and when you
start to raise you know the standards
that you set for yourself like you know
the guy before the norwegian guys like
you know i put on 45 pounds you know the
last couple years because my head's not
on right and how do i get motivated to
get in the gym and it's like dude just
have the willpower right like want it
bad enough have higher standards for
yourself like when you get out of the
shower and you look in the mirror and
you're fat [ __ ] you don't look good i
like i look at myself and i'm like what
the hell happened to my stomach man i've
been eating too much i've been sitting
around they've locked me down i can't go
out i can't ride my bike i'm [ __ ]
right so it's like i've put on some
weight and i shame myself basically
because i'm always hard on myself so
when you raise your standards for
yourself
you know for what you look like the kind
of money you're going to have the kind
of car you're going to drive kind of
people that you invite in your life the
kind of rooms you want to put yourself
in i always tell you guys
if you're the smartest guy in the room
get the [ __ ] out of the room i routinely
leave rooms that i'm the smartest guy in
right so you know when you raise your
standards for your self-care for the
kind of women that you want you're not
going to deal with the crap right
because like as soon as you're on a
dating app or something like that and
you get a match and she's like um i've
got these seven red flags
unmatch you just go because you've got
other options right because you've got
higher standards and you don't allow
that in your life
um what do you do in chile you said that
you're working right now are you in
school so i'm going to get to that point
because that's
the actual question i want to ask
because the other thing is it's just so
people in the chat realize that this
talk is real that the things that are on
your book at 100 percent real and
applicable to real life and because it
happened
so when i tell you that
that she destroyed my life is because i
i started dating her again like we
lasted like one week and then i realized
that
the guy that was calling her was her
boss and she was banging the guy and
it's like an
dude women are the same all around the
world
and i was heartbroken to be honest
because i was really really beta i need
brokers to the point
it's because you believed in the soul
mate myth like you thought that you know
she could be one
hook line
absolutely yeah so i i fell into a very
deep depression like
deep depression because that was coupled
with the fact that i started to realize
that i was a diplomat was
a complete lie something that i i don't
want it to be a part of
because for
the the meaning of the word glamour
right something that appears to be one
thing but it's not like from the outside
it looks very
honorable like helping people solving
proper problems dealing with migration
crisis but when you enter you realize
that inside it's just like a regular
nine to five
with the difference that people inside
they believe
their own stuff they believe that they
are really important
people don't don't do much you don't do
much
and i couldn't stand the fact that i was
sitting from 9 to 5 doing basically
nothing like answering some
emails from the
chilean mission what did you do you
moved on another job
no i i didn't i didn't oh you're
considering leaving
no
it's worse than that because okay so
what's the question because i need to
start to wrap it up yeah i i know so so
okay i want to so the thing is that
because of my medical condition all that
i had to take to leave and
they didn't like that so eventually but
fire from
okay and the thing is that i'm now in
the position where i want to
start from scratch and dedicate myself
to
something that i actually believe in and
that i want to be a part of i decided
that i want to become a bodybuilder i
would like to start a youtube channel
talking about this stuff and okay and
develop i'm making my life
out of that
right so i would like so
you want to be a fitness influencer
but in bodybuilding
okay this is i don't see myself working
at the nine to five okay this is in my
wheelhouse so how old are you and
yeah um
um
i am
31 right now and you want to be a
professional bodybuilder or you want to
be like a fitness influencer
um
i would like to be a professional
bodybuilder if i if i can if i can
you're
you're crazy no no don't listen uh like
you're gonna have to take copious
amounts of steroids right i mean you're
talking about like the professional
scene not the drug tested stuff you know
where you're natural
i mean if i have to i will
yeah like you're going to do a number on
your body and a lot of these guys die
young because they get addicted to
the whole rush of like i need to look
good and it's like well if that guy's
using this thing i think he might be
using so i know how to use that thing
and then you know you go from just using
something basic like
therapeutic testosterone dosages to
throwing the entire kitchen sink into it
you [ __ ] up your health you know you
stress out your organs um you know your
kidneys potentially fail you know
younger than what they need to
and um you know you do it for what to
look good for a couple of pictures
women don't really like guys that look
like that you know women want a guy that
you know like has like a swimmer's body
they generally don't like the
bodybuilder look there's some
bodybuilder chicks that like it of
course but then you know they're kind of
weird looking it's like a dude with like
you know a vagina sort of thing they're
not good looking in my view i mean i'm
just not attracted to them is what i
should say but
i personally would not recommend it to
to guys i mean you're far better off
doing something like like what go
gallagher did like um i did a uh
a pretty long cast with greg like i
don't know two two months ago it's on my
plane to win series i'd recommend
watching it so if you guys watch youtube
find it on youtube just search for greg
gallagher or on spotify or itunes or
whatever you know just search for the
episode on playing the win because it's
also on podcast now and
i mean he's got a great physique he's a
good-looking guy you know gets the girls
that he wants but he runs it as a
business
right like he's selling people
the superhero
like image like these are the exercises
that you do buy my program and i'll
teach you how to look that way go do the
work you know here's some of my
you know supplements and stuff like that
that's the way that you want to do it
and you don't have to be a bodybuilder
to do that you just have to look good
right like
i had dinner with greg um
i don't know a month or so ago like that
he's he's maybe like 5 foot 10 180
pounds he's not a big guy like he's not
like like this like he has to walk in
sideways to get in her room because the
doorway is too too narrow he's he's an
average you know sort of sort of bill
but with the right lighting and with you
know with the right sort of uh program
in
marketing which he's got down pat he
does very well right he's a canadian guy
right so i mean if you look at look at
that episode for some inspiration
don't go competing on stage flexing you
know bikini short sort of stuff like
that i would go the route of
hey you know i know about this stuff i'm
good at it i've been doing it my entire
life and you have to have social proof
like you actually have to look good
right i mean you have to be able to take
off your shirt and be like you know yo
like i'm jack like if you do what i tell
you to do then you can look like this
too right
and that could be good right i mean
one of the areas that you can make a lot
of money on especially online is showing
people how to look good naked
right
because they know that it works
the name is greg
uh greg o'gallagher and it's on the
plane to win podcast
that's a different focus or just a
section of the it's on my youtube
channel just go to playlist and then
look at the playlist that says playing
the win and then just go back uh the
last i think four or five episodes it's
in there
yeah absolutely thanks rich i don't want
to take any more of your time you've
been wonderful thanks a lot thanks
brother good luck hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you